Speaker 1: All right. Let's take a look at a
couple of other things. You know, one of the
things I really hate is hypocritical people and
people who project who say year this year, this
year, this when really I'm the one who is this?
And there is no greater example of this than the
right's view on speech and free speech. And we are
all about being the party of speech. We saw during
COVID that what they claimed to be wanting to be
the party of free speech became something very
different. It became, we get to tell everyone what
content they have to allow on their platform. Wait
a second. Doesn't Twitter then before it was owned
by Elon Musk, doesn't Twitter have these almost
godlike free speech rights as a company which
we shouldn't regulate to decide what sort of
content do they want on on their platform? That's
their speech. No, they should be forced to allow
people to spread drinking, urine, cures, COVID or
whatever it is that they want to spread. We know
that they are complete and total hypocrites. And I
have, unfortunately, a downright dangerous example
of this for you today. Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker says that he wants
protesters arrested. If they're protesting
after 5 p.m., it's not a free speech zone.
It's a free speech time. You can have the free
speech during business hours on weekdays, and if
you've got to work a job, then screw you. Sorry,
you can't protest. Listen to this one thing.
Speaker 4: People got upset about me because it
hurts. Everybody's right to a peaceful protest.
And I know during these times we have, we can
put something in and place it as a peaceful
protest. Let's say a peaceful protest from
eight in the morning to five an hour. Yeah,
half the night. That means the.
Speaker 1: Host.
Speaker 4: Loves it. Be proud. And so you need to
go home. They all get arrested. They're from Dens
and they are movie. You either want to go home
or go to jail because it is not peaceful anymore.
Speaker 2: Right?
Speaker 1: By definition.
It's not peaceful after 5 p.m.. I guess if you
have a day day job. Sorry, you can't protest. This
is not free speech, my friends. The government
shall not and not infringe on anyone's speech.
Before 5 p.m. and then after 5 p.m.,
everybody's got to go home. Now,
there's two different layers to this. Okay.
I unders to pretend that Herschel Walker has
any idea what he's talking about for
a second. I am open to the idea that
a 3 a.m. protest is far more likely to degenerate
into trouble and violence and whatever than a
6 p.m. protest. I'm with you on that. Most
municipalities already have noise ordinances
and all sorts of other infrastructure which apply
rules about blocking streets and sidewalks and
all sorts of different things. Okay, but the idea
that 8 to 5 is when any kind of protest is allowed
isn't supportive of free speech, isn't supportive
of exactly the values that these Republicans claim
to be supportive of. Now, I don't really expect
Herschel Walker to know or understand any of this
as he quite literally as he runs for Georgia
Senate from his house in Texas. That's his
Texas house. That's basically where he lives. The
idea of, well, he Georgia, okay, let's not even
get into that. But the imagery is particularly
stunning here. He doesn't understand anything
that's going on. But it is yet another example
of how these Republicans claim to be all about a
and sometimes they are quite literally against a.
And as is again the case. We have to take a step
back and say, is this the intent of those who
were the creators of the Constitution and the
framework that we have in the United States when
it comes to not just issues of speech, but issues
of freedom of and from religion, where now they
say, well, freedom from religion, not really. And
by freedom of religion, really, they're talking
about Christianity and oh, okay. So freedom
of and from religion actually really just means
establishing Christianity. Okay. You go through
these one by one by one and you start to see they
don't actually practice what they preach when the
rubber hits the road or when it comes time to put
your money or whatever phrase you want to use.
It's just stuff that they say until it
becomes inconvenient. That's the bottom line